welcome to the daily climate show coming
up we report from sweden where the
country is pursuing energy security
through an ambitious green energy
transition
well germany with the same goal
says some states should turn over two
per cent of their land to wind farms
and a warning on warming 200 000 homes
at risk along england's coastlines a
detailed look at the damage to come from
rising sea levels
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we examine the big solutions to the
climate crisis track the changes
happening to the planet and report on
the impact those changes are already
having
and we start today with news of a big
potential solution in part at least to a
problem many parts of the world are
grappling with
an energy crunch intensified by russia's
invasions mean any
many are looking to exploit more fossil
fuels as we reported on the programme
yesterday however sweden wants to pursue
a green and secure future with an
ambitious energy transition a
state-backed project to produce steel
without using fossil fuels a world first
has started supplying two car companies
in a bid to decarbonize heavy industry
our climate change and energy
correspondent hannah thomas peter is in
sweden for us at the hybrid steel pilot
site
i'm at the steel production facility in
sweden which has the potential to
transform the steel manufacturing
industry let me tell you a little bit
about it this is the basic ingredient in
making steel these are iron ore pellets
now in traditional steel making
you would melt these in a blast furnace
by burning coal that's why the steel
industry is such a polluting industry
accounts for about eight percent of
global carbon emissions but what they've
done here
is they've just decided to use hydrogen
made using electrolysis which is uh
fueled by clean green electricity
they're using that hydrogen to replace
the coal in the process and what happens
once they combine the iron ore pellets
with the hydrogen is they make iron
like this this is sponge iron
this sponge iron then gets
melted squashed into these iron
briquettes and they go off get alloys
added and it creates steel
now it sounds relatively simple but
swapping coal for hydrogen
essentially eliminates carbon emissions
and that is what is transformative
about this technology it's not widely
available yet starting to go into some
products in volvo for example
but it is more expensive and the big
question is will manufacturers and
ultimately consumers
be happy to pay that green premium to
start with
in order to get this technology off the
ground and in global circulation
well the green steel pilot is an example
of how a country can continue on the
quest for net zero while providing
domestic energy security and sweden
believes that the scheme can be an
example to others especially in europe
who remain heavily committed to fossil
fuels
the need for
for europe and the whole world to stop
using fossil fuels is immense that job
must continue at a rapid pace what this
crisis what this invasion aggression
that russia is doing against ukraine has
shown is that we need to even further
speed up this process and if there is
anything sweden can do is to lead by
example and show how we can we can
be less dependent on fossil in general
but specifically on russian energy
imports
let's get a bit more of today's climate
news now 10 eu countries led by denmark
have released a joint statement warning
of attempts by other member nations to
water down the region's green deal
austria spain and ireland were among the
countries who co-signed the letter ahead
of a crucial vote on the bloc's 2030
climate goals which are focused around
cutting emissions by 55
by the end of the decade from 1990
levels
german states may soon have to allocate
a minimum of two percent of its land to
wind farms under a plan approved by the
government today the proposed
legislation would have the wind power
goals enforced by 2032 as part of
germany's aim to generate 80 of its
electricity from renewables by the end
of the decade energy security concerns
have sped up germany's green power plans
in the wake of russia's invasion of
ukraine
at least six people have died in china
and 200 000 have been evacuated as
torrential rain continues to flood
southern parts of the country in the
shanghai province river levels are
expected to rise further in the coming
days the damage in that area alone has
already cost more than 13 and a half
million pounds
now sea level rise will put nearly 200
000 homes at risk around england's
coastline by 2050 that's according to
new research published today
they're homes that are unlikely to be
saved because they'll end up being too
expensive to save or too complex to try
to save them the value of those homes
adds up to billions of pounds and the
sea level rise is now almost inevitable
that's because glaciers and ice caps are
melting and ocean waters expand as they
warm
in 20 local authorities across england
thousands of properties are forecast to
be at risk of needing to be abandoned
these areas are expected to have the
most number of properties in danger
including along the west sussex coast
from where madeleine radcliff reports
well i'm in ada on the south coast of
england it's one of the areas which the
report mentions are being at risk from
rising sea levels and when you look at
the town it's very easy to see why
because it's incredibly flat and
incredibly low lying built all the way
along the beach and the only thing
protecting those houses from the rising
sea is this big shingle bank that's been
built up and the groins those huge rock
slabs which are designed to slow coastal
erosion and try and keep the rising
tides at bay but these existing defenses
may not be enough the report says and
people could still have to move further
inland
the residents i spoke to here say that's
an incredibly scary thought but it
certainly hasn't stopped the developers
from building here
people should not build houses
here
this tiny strip it's an amazingly small
in a few hundred yards from the river to
here it's a ridiculous place to build
houses it's very worrying because i'm
just down there i'm only about five
minutes walk from the beach
so yes
um i can't imagine that happening look
at all the building that's going on
along the coast here already well it's
scary in it i mean because where i live
in lansing i mean we're quite flat so it
comes over the beach it's going to go up
right up to the main road
i mean the main road floods now is bad
enough and there's putting new estates
up there
and finally you might have noticed it's
getting a little warm out there the met
office is expected to confirm today as
the hottest day of the year so far with
the mercury set to eclipse the record of
27 and a half degrees set in mid-may
they say it marks the start of a heat
wave with temperatures in parts of the
southeast possibly soaring to 34 degrees
on friday the uk reached 34 degrees in
june three times in the past six years
but before that the last time was in
1976.
that is all from us for now thanks so
much for watching